how does the camera lens capture truth
we're all interested in truth
right I'm talking not about a
mathematical proof nor a physics account
of the universe nor the rules that
govern biology or DNA this is all of
course crucially important but it is not
the subject of this reflection I am
talking actually more about the truth
that sets us free Eric Davis calls
poetic truth or the realm of poetic
facts
early humans sat around the campfire and
told stories storytelling it is said
helps us structure and pattern the mind
we can't think about our own thinking
without some kind of autobiographical
story telling that contextualizes us as
free agents operating in the world and
so we use stories we use myths to
understand ourselves to gain insight
into ourselves and yet in empirical
terms myths are fictions how to
reconcile then
that's something like a mish like a
story can be fiction from the outside
but true from the inside true in that
it's lessons are real its lessons are
valuable its lessons have something
objectively important to teach us about
ourselves and about the world and thus
they are useful fiction they are
truthful and fictions
Channy how this works the paradoxic
ality storytellin right you've heard the
line that says sometimes fiction is more
truthful than reality we rely upon
novelists to conjure up worlds from
their imagination to exteriorize their
flights of fancy to construct to concoct
worlds of fiction manufactured realities
within which of course we can find great
truth this extends as well to cinema to
all forms of art cinema is truth twenty
four times per second 24 frames per
second of truth in the movies art is the
lie that reveals the truth
this this is fascinating to me you know
Alan Dibble tone as well he says poetry
subjective truth may be less accurate
than journalism in describing the
details of an event but may nevertheless
reveal truths beyond the literal
grid so the truth of Miss the truth of
music the truth of fiction the truth of
poetry is beyond naive realism
and this is fascinating to me because
to account for the human experience one
must account for both sides right
for science and arts for empirical truth
and poetic truth and Ursula Le Guin
tried to reconcile these worlds in her
famous idiom our famous quote that
science describes accurately from a
Meowth
that poetry describes accurate
the inside that
objectivity expertise
that poetry in
what they described where that line in
Dead Poets Society when Robin Williams
tells us of course at science
engineering mathematics these are noble
pursuits necessary to sustain life like
poetry
heart
things we stay alive for
being a spiring artists and the truth
lover and a light chaser I need to find
ways of enter me
right
as medical truth objective truth with
the truth
[Music]
so at the risk of repeating myself let
us together in concert reaffirm that
something can be false from the outside
but true from the inside that there is
utility in truthful fiction that art can
be the lie that reveals the truth and
that without music life would be a
mistake this my friends is what I
believe this fuels the work that I do
the content that I make the songs that I
sing the tightrope that I walk the line
I told between chaos and order the flow
I find between discipline and surrender
this is how
find our way this is how all
contradictions are reconciled and this
is how
we surpass
[Music]
yes
Cheers
[Music]